hello
i'm alexander rose i'm the executive
director here at long now i'm coming to
you live
from our headquarters and the bar and
cafe
of the interval where a week ago we
filmed tonight's talk with
lonnie j abby brooks when we film here
during the pandemic we make sure to keep
our staff and speakers as safe as
possible by wearing mass and keeping
distancing
and but mainly tonight i'm really
excited to have lonnie here
uh he is a past collaborator with long
now on our educational initiatives
and a talk on afrofutures is truly long
overdue for us
lonnie's been immersed in the world of
futures thinking for decades and more
recently in afrofutures
and tonight he's going to talk to us
about that journey and
really about broadening the space for
futures thinking in general
because the more perspectives uh that we
have on this
it truly makes us all richer and have
more interesting features so welcome
lonnie j avi brooks
thank you thanks xander it's great to be
back here and this is a nice homecoming
i've worked with the long now foundation
with our long-term and futures thinking
project at cal state east bay
and in working with the institute for
the future as a research affiliate has
been
wonderful in terms of really bringing to
light
afrofuturism and so i'm happy to be back
here
but first let me talk a little bit about
my own journey how i got here
you know i think it was the debut of
wired magazine when it first came out
that i was like i fell in love with um
these images of the future i became an
intern for the institute for the future
and actually wrote my dissertation on
them but then i also realized
wow the future is overwhelmingly white
here so when i
became immersed in the professional
areas of foresight with the institute
for the future
you know they have a tradition of really
talking about the future
and pioneering that tradition as a
nonprofit
they've also you know had to have a
variety of clients
that are more corporate focused more
consumer focused you know practical
and it makes sense it's you know they're
trying to you know survive as futurists
right it's not easy and so in that sense
though
it leaves a gap right because if you're
just talking about
how people are mapping how corporations
are mapping out our lives
10 to 50 to 100 years from now or how
consumers will spend their money in the
future
you're you're glossing over a lot of
people's in the world that respond
to imagination differently what it means
to me
is that you know after years of growing
up
and largely not seeing black people
represented in the future you know every
straight white male gets the privilege
of having seen their own superhero
someone reflecting them
in movies of science fiction and fantasy
so we see george justin and his wife and
the closest thing that you get to
resembling a black figure is maybe the
sassy maid
you know the robot who's had enough at
times
i contributed to this wonderful
anthology called afrofuturism 2.0
i have chapter eight it's called playing
a minority forecaster
in search of afrofuturism where am i in
this future stuart brand
it's a nice homage to stewart in many
ways and also a critique
but it's great because really it's about
how do we find our futures to make sure
that black futures matter here
so i share a dream to ensure
that long oppressed racial minority and
diverse voices
can articulate themselves in the futures
imagined
in the practices of long-term thinking
and in the professional areas of
foresight
celebrating the black imagination black
people have always been futurists
you see we have to be afrofuturism
claims to reclaim
and transform the trauma of past
atrocities
against the black and afro-queer
diaspora
afrofuturism combined science fiction
and fantasy
to re-examine how the future is
currently imagined
to envision alternative futures based on
the black experience
as slavery forced africans to confront
an alien world
surrounded by colonial technologies
afrofuturism
is born out of cruelty and that cruelty
of the white imagination
and some complicity with the african
imagination as well
was a necessary condition out of which
the african diaspora had to reimagine
its future
you see the black experience is
futuristic it's more like a middle
passage
it's a science fiction horror story you
know think about this
west africa as our the home planet of
the black diaspora
where with the latest in bondage
technologies
we were transported against our will in
ships
designed to carry rows and rows of
people and chains
and once they got to this alien world in
the americas they were killed if they
spoke
their language or tried to practice
their religion or play their music
in this world they had to innovate adapt
capitulate succumb and rebuild
their former lives and traditions they
were sold
auctioned off to the nearest bidder
families torn apart
they had to reinvent themselves and
create new black technologies
to repair the trauma they had just
experienced
and keep experiencing they were
innovators in an
alien landscape you see they had to
create what scholars call sonic utopias
they're future scenarios spirituals are
future scenarios envisioning zion
it's our vibranium you know the metal
that helped build wakanda this fantastic
metal that you could apply in different
ways
but spirituals were also coded signals
of future liberation
you know that tune swing low sweet
chariot
it's cold for movement something's
getting ready to happen
looked over jordan what did i see it's a
coded metaphor for the ohio river
for slaves that could escape into canada
a band of angels coming after me it's
called for conductors
gonna help me get my freedom so the
spiritual the dance the art
is our cultural vehicle our spaceship
transporting the black imagination to
our future selves and generations
this is our truth our currency our power
and thus we are vibranium
so really when we talk about imagining
afrofutures we're talking about
imagining tracing and recovering
afrofutures
and what does that mean yeah
afrofuturism 1.0
really emerged in the 1940s with sun raw
post world war ii and pre-emergence of
the world wide web
and that emerged to describe the
african-americans imaginations
and engagement with science fiction
music art technology
if you think about there's a guy named
helmut
and a voice spoke to him in the early
40s and said hey
you know what black people came from
another planet
you should stop doing what you're doing
and work on your music
and this person became son raw the early
jazz musician
who innovated in jazz and art
and created his own band that's here
with us today
and it really ushered in kind of this
wave
of afrofuturism experimentation with art
and music it was going on before but
this is where it really takes on kind of
an otherworldly
feeling let's take a listen to sunra for
a minute too so you can kind of hear
how he's experimenting with the future
[Music]
we have the mothership connection with
parliament funkadelic
that continues in with george clinton
and that music
continuing with that we have public
enemy and their album fear of a black
planet
and then we have illustrious writers
like samuel delaney
and octavia butler samuel delaney etches
out this queer
alien world in dahlgren and octavia
butler talks about
imperable the sower about this
miraculous
woman who lives in the year 2020s
where society is collapsing around them
they have a president who ignores
the marginalized and so
she's embodies this empathic power
to be able to feel what people are
feeling and she leads her community up
north
to recreate a new type of world
for them and octavio butler wrote this
in the late 90s
now we come to afrofuturism 2.0
and this is another wave the rise of
astro blackness
and the black bucket of arts movement
we're actually in afrofuturism 2.0 right
now afrofeatures and blossoms into
all these different types of genres and
there's even new ones emerging like
african futurism
and black quantum futurism too there's a
great
quote from and term from the reverend
andrew rollins
that talks about the rise of astro
blackness
it's about a person's black state of
consciousness
released from a confining and crippling
colonial enslaved mentality who becomes
aware of the multitudes
and varied possibilities and
probabilities within the universe
so astro blackness shifts us from this
modern era
of blackness to a planetary perspective
in response to the challenges facing
black life
in the early 21st century now
i call 2018 the year of the panther when
the black panther film came out
and you know was wondering like how did
futurism 2.0 end up on
local abc news as i did i was able to
articulate
what the black panther meant to me the
smash
box office hit and i can tell you when i
was at the community screening
at the grand theater in oakland i was
thrilled first of all to see oakland on
the screen being portrayed
and then next flying into this beautiful
etch city of wakanda it's the whole
community in the theater we're just like
yes you know it's just one of those
moments
you see there was this exhibition going
on in
the schoenberg center for the study of
uh black studies
it was called the alchemy of the black
imagination and you had this wonderful
exhibition
of fantastic artwork that imagined
black people on different planets in the
galaxy
on earth with new types of technologies
it extends what afrofuturism 2.0 does
is it extends the edges of radical black
art
it's transnational it's trans contextual
it's diasporic it's a cultural worldview
for interrogating eurocentric motifs
the linear constructions of past
present and future so it goes further it
extends afrofuturism 1.0
even more you know tiffany barber and
ronaldo anderson have this wonderful
quote where they say the black angel
of history has traveled across beyond
space and time
to prepare us for a future african zion
beyond this place of wrath and tears
see it carries and extends where we've
been before
so 2.0 the version of afrofuturism
extends the reach of radical black
visual art literature
theater social and applied sciences and
critical theory in the u.s
and so the alchemy of the black
imagination ushered in this wonderful
movement
called the black speculative arts
movement that was co-founded by ronaldo
anderson
and john jennings and others you see the
one thing i want to make clear here too
is
i'm one head talking but with me and
alongside me
are thousands hundreds millions of
people
that are part of this wave of
afrofuturism
some people are into african futurism
black quantum futurism and the black
speculative arts movement
it's a wave that we're experiencing
and we're just riding that wave right
now
you see it's all about tracing the black
fantastic less than two percent of card
carrying professional futurists
identify as black but that doesn't mean
there aren't plenty of black futurists
and foresight strategists and futures
visionaries abundant in the streets the
arts
at the protests in tech labs
so tracing the black fantastic refers to
what richard iton
talks about the minor key sensibilities
generated from the experiences of the
underground
you see we can see it around us right
now the protests going on
across the nation those minor keys are
being
played tested experimented extended
so tracing the black fantastic means to
recover
past progressive liberating alternative
futures and sprouting them into the
present
we also have these fantastic science
fiction authors women authors
who are breaking barriers like nk
jemisin with this season
and binti by nedia core4 winning hugo
and nebula science fiction awards we
have graphic novels coming out like the
black panther party an infant item by
tim fielder
that really talk and meet the past with
the president you see the black panther
party
began in the 60s and when i looked at
their 10-point program
i agreed with every point they made they
were talking about reparations
free access to quality health care and
education
where we realized that in the film of
the black panther
and are still struggling with that right
now in 2020 unbelievable but we are
and we have this wave and renaissance of
movies like sorry to bother you
and the black klansmen and these
wonderful
murals that were up on 9th street in
oakland by tarika lewis
that proclaimed wakanda and oconda here
are ready to interrogating you know
this lineage of black history in oakland
there's erica huggins too a former
leader of the black panther party
who envisions how to speak about white
privilege
and so it's we have these leaders
these these elders like terrika lewis
and erica huggins and angela davis
who are our sages who are these black
visionary thinkers that are still alive
we are learning so much from them
so tracing the black fantastic as our
cultural vibranium
it's about reading their radically
hopeful possibilities into a future
augmented with progressive values and
fused with more a black soul
you know clr james really has this great
quote he talks about that the
fundamental task
is to recognize the democratic socialist
aflo queer utopia society and record the
facts of his
existence so that we can see these
scenes and moments are read as outposts
of a new society
and walking around oakland especially
right now
in san francisco and oakland you see
these wonderful art pieces
done by black artists and some white
artists too
talking about their inspirations about
the future where black lives matter
now in order to trace this
and what's been happening in terms of
black futures thinking i came up with a
term
called afrofuture types so future types
trace
the circulating science fiction capital
filled with promises of the future
that can simultaneously constrain and
unleash our imaginations
so afrofuture types are black signals of
the future
that find and reclaim the traces of
black cultural visions
alongside erasures of those very signals
too
you see it wasn't until recently that i
even knew
about black wall street in tulsa
oklahoma that
a signal a beacon of black liberation
black imagination was literally
bombed to the ground hundreds if not
thousands of people
died in unmarked graves and those
remaining folks were herded into a
concentration camp
the literal erasure of an ascendant
people
that just a few generations before had
been enslaved
that's a black signal worth talking
about
investigating amplifying revisiting
and amplifying it more brainy you know
once
said you know what computing needs is
more soul well we're in the age of
artificial intelligence
how do we make sure that artificial
intelligence
has an african soul you see it really
reflects
where the afrocentric view shifts this
emphasis from opposing binaries
to juxtaposing dimensions where a range
of truths can be held to create
and these foundations to understand
quantum computing have been among
black people for centuries to hold the
one and zero simultaneously
so what if what would artificial
intelligence look like
if it was infused with afroqueer and
afroqueer a.i
the afrofuture center of perspective is
intersectional
and rejects binaries for a long while
now futures thinking
and afrofuturism haven't really
addressed
the plight of trans black bodies of
queer people
and their tradition in our tradition and
it wasn't until recently that the
national lgbtq task force
apologized to trans people for ignoring
them
and we have in the past you know in the
past several years
uh trans people who are being killed are
alarming weight and they're black trans
people
and so we want to make it clear that
black trans lives matter
that black queer people matter
i'm a product of multiple identities
growing up in los angeles
and even in los angeles as as black and
jewish
and queer and you know i was um
i had to navigate numerous types of
identities
and i just remember this point in 1983
where i was in class with my english
teacher at fairfax high school in los
angeles and he begins the class
proclaiming you were all
homosexual we looked at each other kind
of scared
initially shocked wondering how did he
know that about us
his point and you know it's not a new
one but queerness in most everything
else is on a spectrum
we are all queer and partake in
queerness
and queer time and i think it's an
important point to understand
how time can get out of its linear
construction
that we can talk actually talk about
what queer time might mean
see the black experience shapes our
lives afo queerness is part of our dna
part of that is really starting with the
birth of our species
you know 150 000 years or so ago
where we didn't have terms like queer or
homosexual or homophobia
and what life could have been like there
and to kind of imagine it
at the birth of our human species we had
queerness weaved within it
if we look to indigenous tribes they
have a
a space for gender fluidity
a third gender gender fluid pathways
that they celebrate people who are
genderfluid in native american tribes
and in aboriginal tribes are shamans
they're healers they're future
visionaries
you know this is really excellent
statuette of the first people having sex
that was ever discovered they're just
wrapped around each other and you can't
tell
what their gender is and i think that
really encapsulates
afroqueer and queer time
we can trace afroqueerness in egypt
there's also a tale of two manicurists
for the
pharaoh and when they rediscovered their
tomb
it shows them with their noses together
and mouths almost nearly together and
that's a sure sign that they were a
couple
because usually it was of opposite sexes
but it shows them together and they were
revered
and it wasn't a problem or as the clone
as the colonists arrived to the african
continent
and tried to make tribes shamed for
their fluid gender pathways and so and
we're still struggling with it right
there's this you know
big a big sort of uh eurocentric
christianity abounded in africa that
doesn't recognize lgbtq rights
so i want to sort of come back to kind
of pre-colonial times
this existence and uh and there's you
know really great activists in africa
working
in the african nations working on this
too uh
to really bring queer futures and black
lives to the forefront and making that
connection
and keep making that connection you know
a great collaborator of mine
naija whitson at uc riverside she's
working on
this great essay called superfluid super
black
and they flirt claim in this fantastic
quote i am a black queer trans
non-bearing
artist flowing fluently like the memory
of my super fluid sleeping ancestors and
transistors
as my elder ef fuyakati often reminds me
if we are then someone else in our line
was we are not the first
and so that's really important because
if you think about it
in what w b du bois talks about double
consciousness they have a heightened
consciousness
they're able to see the fluid
intersections of identities that they're
living with on a daily basis
to guide their tribe and so i think you
know 150 000 years ago this must be
queer time this is queer time they
didn't have the terms for it
but i feel like it's time to really
acknowledge within the black tradition
that queerness has existed there's this
great documentary film artist
leo herrera who completed this project
called
the father's project if they lived and
he creates a series of four documentary
fictional film documentaries
about what would have happened if
the leaders during the aids epidemic had
lived
and we can't really imagine this creates
a queer future world
where the queer colonies have flourished
and he talks about the political
influence of these queer colonies
on the rest of the u.s and that the
queer colonies are becoming their own
autonomous regions
which i love as well too and so through
a series of four films
he leads us through these fantastic
images
that end you know finally also evokes
one of the leaders of appdap who's
running for president
in 2020. and uh so
these these types of things really
inspire me
to proclaim queer time continues with us
so i also aim to clear the categories of
forecasting future studies and foresight
as they are practiced
so it comes from a long tradition of
african culture
that really didn't see race and class in
the same way that we do
it recognizes the interconnectedness of
all things
into which is bound to for
interconnectedness
it gives you a wider aperture on the
future where so many
corporations and organizations and
government agencies have tried to see
the future through a straw
seeing it through black perspectives
opens it up so you can see
signals and black signals and
afrofeature types happening on the
streets in front of you
so they're getting there but you know as
a movement the black speculative arts
movement and afrofuturism
uh really had to have to speak to black
futures
that just wasn't being done but the
black speculative arts movement
we call it b stamp for short these bcm
festivals that have been going on across
the country
they've been expanding in the u.s
embraced by canada
in europe and in south africa
the sheer poster art itself visibly done
by stacy robinson and others
is worthy of an exhibition i was lucky
to have the chance to be part of a
futures
computer mixed reality lab called
dynamic lab
and they were opening themselves up to
the community to see
how their mixed reality technology could
help augment
the future visions of their communities
surrounding them and i got this vision
of what if we had a map of wakanda and
as we went through the different regions
of wakanda we saw people's alternative
visions of the future
so we actually created a little demo of
that and it was really fun to
to see it come into existence and we
even put bosco conti there to
singing afrofuturism in this little
blurb
you know ahmed best he played jar jar
binks in star wars
he he came to uh the studio uh
with a with an idea of a black uh star
trek comedy
and they were like what are you what are
you saying black people aren't
interested in the future
and that really struck me and him that
wow
you know the white patriarchal structure
doesn't get it
that afrofuturism is something that
can feed not only black souls but
everyone's soul
in creating more varieties of
imagination
in talking we kept coming back to the
same point
that usually when we're in the room
where the only people of color talking
about the future
and he said why don't we create a
podcast together
so we did and we call it the
afrofuturist podcast where i met for an
hour
with one one-on-one has these in-depth
conversations
with people that we don't usually see so
the afrofeatures podcast
is in its third year right now and so
we are trying to uncover the stories
of black people and others that are
doing work about the future so that's
part of what we do
so at dynamic land i met a great white
ally of mine
and friend eli kosminski and
together we created a game
called afro rhythms from the future we
really realized we needed a game that
spoke to the black experience
and to people of color and indigenous
people we decided to take an existing
forecasting game called the things in
the future
a great game by stuart candy and jeff
watson
we've uh playtested this game in a
number of venues and with the
help of a research creative research
group called the fathomers
it's a card deck of about 100 cards
people have different roles that they
play
as traveler seer or elder and
they then get dealt a set of cards to
play their role
now this game what we've noticed and
from
folks like jake dunnigan and dave
mcgonagall who've done work on this
day mcgonagall was super better in using
games to heal people
we've thought about this game as a way
to help rework
our memories rework black memories
by creating new scenes and new futures
that renew positive associative neural
pathways you see the regions of the
brain
that celebrate the past or that form the
past
also form our futures in the same
regions through mri studies
so what if we used gaming to heal trauma
as a call for a futures therapy of the
mind
to jam and heal the epigenetics of black
trauma
what if we create this community futures
literacy program
with a black perspective in mind that
can support healing young and adult
minds
the california blacks bucket of arts
movement is launching in july
and in partnership with the museum of
children's arts moca
and game heads we're about to launch our
2020
imagining with afrofuturism initiative
the black future school the community
future school that is
where black futures matter we're really
intentionally thinking about the
community future school to increase the
literacy
of futures thinking with everyone
starting with the black perspective in
mind
because what we're noticing with
activists and people right now
that the movement needs an imagination
to think further
and it's provocative too like defunding
the police is great as a provocative
point to talk about the redistribution
of resources or to increase resources
for everything
and how do we use that as a starting
point to recreate and reimagine our
core institutions so having a community
future school in place
with young people young adults older
people people in general
where black futures matter will help to
enable people to see the signals around
them of the future
and to weave them in storytelling
scenarios that they share with each
other
through our game through other types of
games to really
envision the future of their communities
together what we envision is an
equitable futures network of california
a regional network where communities
from indigenous people to lgbtq
communities can share and demonstrate
and showcase their visions of the future
and so i've decided to do a a series of
short vignettes about the future
headlines of the future they're called
black af
scenarios in the news and if you get the
term black af you know what i'm talking
about
so 2020 the non-profit california black
speculative arts movement launches in
july to promote black speculative art
and design with its partners
the museum of children's art game heads
and ancestral futures
in 2020 the election is in dispute the
military intervenes with supreme court
approval
as biden assumes the presidency the u.s
goes into a restorative justice healing
and national reconciliation to honor
black lives
to apologize for slavery it becomes a
catalyst for reparations
as the first stage of the cares act
creating a responsible and equitable
society
fast forward to 2022 california b sam
participates in the first california
equitable futures network
of imagination action conference where
hundreds of
black people of color and lgbtqia
organizations showcase
their community vision futures for 2032.
again we're in 2025 now community
futures school
now has a 1000 alumni with professional
certificates in strategic forecasting
for the communities and are in demand as
foresight
coalition builders wow
2300 now nova africa
l5 space world nation wakanda 5
celebrates its 200th anniversary
with earth and mars black diasporas in
vibranium mine
linkedin to share and leap up
in the anti-gravity ida b wells dance
liberatory design at its finest
i end there saying and want to imagine
afrofutures with you
where black futures matters thank you
thank you lonnie that was um that was
awesome i think
um if nothing else um just getting that
perspective is
so much different than the futures
perspectives then um then we've been
presenting and and seeing already and
you know we had that experience i think
as a nation
as as black panther came out in a broad
spectrum but seeing it
from the perspective of the futures
community which you've now been a part
of
um is is fantastic so thank you and
um how was it working with our team to
put together all those visuals thank you
for helping us with all that
uh that was amazing i uh
i really loved the the that you captured
the artistic uh
artwork that's going on from these you
know very
gifted artists from stacy robinson to
menswell
boseman to katana wind i mean
all these fantastic artists that and
joshua mays
that have helped us before um really are
amplifying their work
because i mean you know what's a
revolution without art what's
transformation without art what is a
black future without art
it's it's pretty boring so you
you want you want to you want to be able
to dance you wanna be able to to enjoy
the music
and and enjoy the art that's surrounding
you and immersing you so
yeah yeah and i think i mean you brought
up this point i think it's it's worth
touching on again which is that you know
we
already are present and and really our
future
is often especially in arts and culture
and design
is already being defined by the black
community
um but they generally aren't thinking of
themselves as futurists
but as artists or designers um but i
think it's a
it's an interesting idea to you know as
you know any anybody who's creating
something that lives onto the future
like a product design or a
piece of music is effectively a um
you know a futurist so it's i think
that's a great point
just can you talk a little bit more
about that
yeah i mean i think um you know stacy
robinson for instance i was just having
a great conversation with him this
morning
about his work in creating black utopias
you know what about creating
more spaces where you enter into and
you're carried to
a spaces of liberation so literally you
know creating exhibitions where you
enter into it
and you feel a sense of relief it's like
hyphen labs did this vr simulation
about um hyper feminist afro
feminist futures and i remember uh
immersing myself in it at the institute
for the futures afrofutures festival
that we had and it was
amazing because i felt a sense of relief
like for a moment i got a sense of being
connected to a broader mind
where we were immersed in feeling
ourselves
as as as free liberated and at home
and it was just an amazing feeling in
that vr simulation
um you know for myself
i also come to it through popular
culture
i was born posturally blind and so i
grew up with star trek
and the only character that i really saw
on star trek was lieutenant hura
in terms of being black and the other
minorities associated
with that but like her for me and
and jordy in the next generation too
right he was blind but we could see
in spectacular visions and so for me
that really meant a lot because it meant
that
um you know i had these star trek uh
posters surrounding me on my walls
and i was really fascinated with
thinking in a bigger
mindset about the future so that's where
i really started on my pathway to
foresight
that um you know how can we think bigger
how can i not be constrained by my
vision and
and literally envision a different way
if i didn't have my physical sense
very good um i just want to remind all
of you that um
that the the channels are open for you
to send uh
questions in through your streams that
you're watching um but
um right now we're gonna bring in uh
ronaldo
anderson um who is a guest uh
invited by lonnie um and um
and and uh ronaldo um i believe you um
you worked you were a co-editor of
afrofuturism 2.0
uh that invited the essay in bailani is
that correct
yes um and that's how lonnie and i
uh initially became connected lonnie and
i
are both members of the national um
ncaa national communication association
so because we both have a
background in train formal training and
communication studies
and that was the connection and i think
lonnie was a perfect fit for some of the
things that i was looking at in relation
to
looking at the future so it was just a
natural fit in terms of what his
research interest was at the time and i
was just very
lucky we were very lucky um that we were
able to
um get him to submit to the uh the not
the first anthology awesome
do you have a question for for lonnie
for after seeing us talk
okay uh lonnie's probably i think we've
talked about this
earlier i know um one of the things i've
talked about
with friends in the last 90 days was
how there was going to be a conception
of afrofuturism
pre-covert 19 and then a
conception of afrofuturism post covert
19.
so i would just want to ask him how does
he how is he
how has the pandemic impacted how he's
thinking about
afrofuturism at the moment especially
the second wave that we've been
a part of the last five years
well you know um i remember hearing a
talk of the lung now actually about
what would happen if we had autonomous
driving and
a speaker there on talking about that
said that it would actually free up a
lot of political energy that has you
know
been channeled into parking your cars
and finding a parking space and driving
in general and i feel like the
the kova 19 has actually unleashed
political energy
and pent up political energy that people
have been able to channel
especially black people and protesters
uh
really seeing you know the time has come
to
really apologize for
enslavement for inequity with the black
community
and that more energy can be poured into
that
and that we can actually um i mean
making use of online space
for black liberation spaces is has been
also wonderful like like uh stacy this
this morning stacey robinson was telling
me about you know all the dj's that were
playing
you know at the beginning of the kobe 19
time and just jamming you know and it's
like wow
you know we're kind of like jamming
ourselves in two and two revolutionary
spins
and i i like that uh and and just and to
see more coalition building
than i have uh witnessed in my lifetime
my lifetime has has been fantastic so i
feel like
there's there's a hope and a promise and
whether it gets fulfilled or not is
really dependent upon
a lot of factors but um i think that
the black expectative arts movement is
at the heart of keeping that forward
momentum and other
you know other movements that are
alongside it
too so um yeah
i'd go on and on but you know what
how do you feel um one of the things
when i'm looking at it going forward i
know um
uh foreign policy and i guess the
council of foreign relations people and
a lot of
prognosticators are now looking at
post covid that there's going to
probably be a return of uh
particular in particular forms of ultra
nationalism
um also that the when it comes to
monetary uh how money and economics is
going to look that the global south is
going to really
uh be hurting as it relates to
certain type of financial practices in
terms of how their currency works
and so that's going to probably lead to
certain
aspects of instability and and
and and since we've built the
international network of the black
speculative arts movement i was just
thinking about
how um it's going to look different
in different parts of the world going
forward i remember when we did our
event in johannesburg the fall of 2018
where a young lady um named nalede
sherwin who's a member of the economic
freedom power
fighters was talking about how their
afrofuturism was going to be growing
from the politics of the stomach
and so and they were really practical
in terms of what it meant for them going
forward
in relation to the land issue in
southern africa
and so um i suspect
uh as i've mentioned from one of the
other co-founders john jennings that
we're
we're going to have pockets of potential
utopia then pockets of dystopia
in the wake of the pandemic depending on
which geographical region of the world
we find ourselves in
but i am seeing a lot of uh
exciting developments that in relation
to technology and coalition building
and um as we're going forward and
and we're now you're seeing a lot more
dialogue around the concept of
acceleration
in terms of how this it seems like even
though we're in july now it almost feels
like january was like a year and a half
ago
or there's so much has happened in the
last six months
and so that's kind of where um people
are right now and
and talking with stacey this thing seems
to be shifting every 90 days
in terms of how uh we're going to have
to respond to it i think uh
we're going to have to be tremendously
flexible uh moving forward as as the
um network and movement keeps moving
forward
and and and turn and i think the the
what the the work that
you've done with the long now foundation
the forecasting part is going to be
uh incred an incredibly valuable tool
to kind of assist other members and
people in the network uh whether they're
in north america or in brazil
or in west africa um we had some events
last year in nigeria and ghana
yeah i i feel like you know um that's
right
on i mean in terms of like we've been
talking about how
local currencies and investing in
cryptocurrencies and digital accordances
is really important too
and developing those and like you know
folks like ingrid lafleur and
other folks that are really learning
how to uh develop uh local
and native currencies that work for our
communities thank you ronaldo
for for that uh and i want to um i want
to invite
ahmed now um as uh lani mentioned
he worked uh with uh ahmed uh
on the most recent podcast but many of
you know him as the voice from jar jar
binks and uh is a futurist in his own
right so welcome ahmed
hello hello how are you good to see you
it looks like you got a very
professional audio set up there it's
nice
you're a voice actor so you must have
this all the time yeah you know with the
knife of the
professional podcaster i started out my
career as a musician
um and so i've had multitudes of
instruments just
follow me through my lifetime and now
they're all
in one place which i'm which i'm very
happy about
um and the other thing about being jar
jar binks is
um i'm often uh
for just being the voice but that's
very a very small part of what i did
um i i was actually the first motion
capture hybrid actor in film history
and when we're talking about black
bodies contributing to the future
and we're talking about black artists
and art contributing to the future
a lot of times our contributions are
not really talked about with the weight
and with the extent that they need to be
talked about
and we don't envision our black artists
as futurists when it comes to our
performance
we mentioned sunra who really started
the idea of this cosmic journey
sonically which parliament funkadelic
picked up
which africa bambada and the so sonic
force picked up in the 80s
which spawned you know cool herc
and all of those cats in the bronx where
i'm from new york city
to invent hip-hop and now you can't find
a song anywhere
that doesn't use any type of technology
and that was black futurists
that was black artists and we create
um the code that societies
then adopt to move the systems forward
and um because i was a
co-creator of the code that created this
entire new form of
filmmaking every film that you see
that has any type of uh cgi
in it has me in it so black people
and african people in the natural sense
of afrofuturism and afrofuturist
thinking
have contributed to industries
um and and the inner workings and the
architecture and the coding of
industries
uh since the beginning of time
thank you um and after seeing i know you
work with lonnie quite a bit but um
after seeing this talk i was wondering
if you had a question
along the lines of uh of the talk as
well
yeah um we haven't really talked about
and
ronaldo and lonnie started leaning into
this a little bit but we haven't talked
about this
idea of um poverty
and um how systems are created
to perpetuate poverty and
how afrofuturists and in afrofutures the
idea of
wealth and the idea of poverty that have
been eurocentric primarily have been
shifted when we're talking about
afrofutures and i would love for lonnie
to elaborate on the idea of
poverty being a system that needn't
exist
and how afrofuturism really lends to
that idea
yeah in fact you know i've been talking
to a lot of folks
including you about developing scenarios
around what does reparations look like
in terms of you know if we can if we can
help um lift uh
help expand health wealth and education
for black people
we can help it for everyone and that
what do what do reparations look like as
a form
that uh enables black people to you know
have
their bodies respected and their minds
expanded
uh from where they are now i mean you
know we've done pretty
relatively well considering all the
obstacles in our face but just think
about the
unleashed economic prosperity of having
a guaranteed
income that supports us that lets us
not just be in jobs that we don't want
to be in
but that support our minds right i mean
if you want to talk about real
prosperity
you'd unleash that so it's it comes down
to political will
you know and so i think that afrofutures
has a lot to to talk about that and
speak to
and uh so i'm excited about trying to
develop those scenarios of operations
what does that look like
and that includes some type of national
reconciliation and actual apology
from the american government to black
people
um you know as a cornerstone of that
absolutely
i think what's really exciting about
what's going on right now especially
with the with the recent uprising is
that
young people um understand that
systems and working within systems don't
have to be the only answer if you think
about it
the generations now they grew up with
systems changing every 18 months
and less right six to 18 months
following
moore's law right so they have no
problem
an operating system go and completely
starting a brand new operating system
now that's them in their computing world
and then their computing world turned
mobile and now their mobile world is
turning
internal and generational so when we
talk about
systems set up um for and lonnie and i
we talk about this all the time but when
we talk about systems
set up to maintain a status quo that
does not really work at the pace in
which
um the people right now the young people
right now are operating
then um it's time for the entire system
to change
and so rather than thinking about things
like how do we deal with waste
we imagine worlds where waste
isn't uh in existence how do we deal
with
poverty we imagine a world where poverty
doesn't exist
and then we work backwards and we figure
out the
steps to get there but the young people
right now
are in such um they're teaching us
so much about how we do not
have to settle for systemic problems
right we can change the system
yeah absolutely i mean you know i'm
inspired by
uh dsd for the future's work on
governance design too that informs our
own work and bridges it to
afrofuturist thinking as well you know
how do we
see our institutions as eroded and
remake them and transform them
and radically change them to meet our
needs you know
i'm inspired by movements like
restorative justice thinking right
that helps people what would a city look
like if it was based on restorative
justice thinking
you know you'd have radically different
ways of policing that would protect
communities
yeah absolutely and we've we talked
about a lot about you know what
ideas of policing are reimagining
policing
and you know this idea of defunding the
police
is um just a a very welcome
start and the addition to defunding the
police is refunding the people
right because when you take that money
away from militarization of the police
force and you put it
back into the communities when you're
talking about education when you're
talking about
you know eradicating food deserts we're
talking about abundance and jobs
all of a sudden a community thrives and
the idea of a militarized police becomes
ludicrous so it's the afrofuturist
thinking
reimagines all of these things based on
our experience
yeah i think that you know the working
backwards um
thing i remember uh seeing an interview
with the woman who is the
um the futurist who designed wakanda and
i loved her description where she says
that the center of the city is the
archive
and the library and the entire thing
spirals out from there and it's it's
this kind of like and uh so she used
this
staple into their future and as to why
their city was so
the past was so important to the city um
to basically design the entire rest of
the city it was a super powerful concept
yeah absolutely and if you think about
the underground railroad
right the underground railroad railroad
encompasses
all of the the what lonnie was talking
about when he was talking about
the parts of the brain that can perceive
the past can also speculate about the
future
right the underground railroad is that
in an actual tangible way of thinking
astronomically
these stars which exploded billions and
billions of light years away
in the past are just now is reaching
the earth and enslaved africans are
using the past light to look towards a
better future
that's the entire scope of what
afrofuturism is
and the ability to perceive both the
past and the future in the exact same
moment
nice i love it that's great well thank
you so much ahmed and can you mention
the name of your podcast again that you
guys do together
the podcast is called the afrofuturist
podcast
um lonnie brooks and i created it
together
and um you could find it on itunes and
stitcher or wherever you get your
podcasts
we talked to speculative fiction artists
technologists um uh we talked to
uh politicians recently which has been
incredibly interesting
designers but everyone who uses
afrofuturist thinking
to move whatever they're doing forward
cool well thank you so much again for
joining us and
we're going to get to some questions
from uh from our audience
um i think there's um
the one of the questions we have from uh
renata baredo of a facebook is
um is actually about the athero rhythms
game and is it available now and
um and where do you get it
yeah that's a great question so we're
actually working on the second uh
stage of that design of the game um and
right now we have an original
uh card deck and uh that that you know
we are willing to uh you know talk with
you about and work with
we're looking forward to our next stage
iteration of this card game
um that will be available through
probably a kickstarter
um but we're also talking to since we're
getting so many inquiries about
it right now we're really excited about
it um we are
going to be um you know just email me
[Laughter]
right well i mean we'll also talk about
it along now as it comes out too so yeah
feel feel free to stay tuned with long
now about it as well
yeah definitely cool um and uh
rafael securos aquarius i believe or
securos from over email asked
how involved scholars are from
sub-saharan africa
and the rest of the african diaspora
outside the us in the
uh afrofuturism movement yeah so
um we have uh
well there was a special issue done by
the journal future studies
on african futures and so
we are in dialogue with them and also
the black specker of arts movement was
just did a series of
b sams in ghana and in
cape town and so it was a like wonderful
moments of connection
uh and stuff that was going on also in
nigeria too
so uh so bsams are sprouting up and it's
kind of this embrace of what
we're calling afrofeatures in 3.0 when
when africa kind of
african nations embrace it too and style
it on their
on their own um you know jeremy
kirschbaum of the institute for the
future is also working with
and highlighting african innovators in
especially nigeria and kenya and other
places
so that's really exciting but the black
speculative
arts movement is really catching on in
terms of
investing in afro-futures thinking with
uh scholars
and uh activists there so
it's going forward um and actually i
mean along those lines uh someone
identifies as africa america on facebook
stream uh mentions that um you know the
ghana is
uh often referred to as a modern day
wakanda um
and um do you have any pros or cons and
how we use it
utilize the positive movement there well
i mean i think the the
the energy there is uh i want to i want
to go to ghana i haven't been there yet
you know and
from what i'm hearing about is just the
idea of how
how folks from america arrive in ghana
feeling more liberated
uh than you know being here in the
states um and how ghana has
celebrated um the anniversary of
slavery by inviting um african americans
to come live there
um so i feel like there's there's lots
of uh potential and promise
in what ghana is doing in in its in its
forward thinking and
foresight so i i'm excited about you
know
there's you know how do we create
wakanda you know uh
and our own vision of it you know that
it's actually more inclusive than maybe
the wakanda we saw in the film
too with uh with afro queer futures as
well
and i i think i want to go back a little
bit to some of the games that you're
working on i mean um
the um stuart candy as a research fellow
here at long now who created that that
card game
uh that thing from the future which you
then uh worked with him sounded like to
adapt this
uh the card game for that and then uh
and then dynamic land over
in the east bay can you dynamic land is
kind of this amazing thing that
i think not enough people know about uh
i was wondering um
if you could just say a little bit more
about how that lab works and and how
your work
there uh dovetailed in yeah that was an
amazing experience
um where they have this loft on 9th
street
and they have rafters of computer
projectors
that project um programs onto
and make uh you know three by five
pieces of paper into playable media
and and the media the paper have colored
dots around them to read
a bar code that then makes the paper
playable
and when we saw that and were immersed
in it the idea was to create
collaboration
across with people in computing rather
than people being on their own
individual screens and on their laptops
and phones
but actually have a collaborative based
computing platform
where people can commute you know can
can do creative things together
and look at each other you know and i
just love that
and so when i met uh eli kozminski
uh we actually did an awful futurist
podcast with uh
some of the interaction designers like
paula uh
too who was there uh and others uh it
was amazing
uh so when i met eli you know he was
really open to thinking about well how
do we
how do we invent wakanda here and uh and
he helped me with his
uh you know access expertise in
computing
to make this dream come alive so when it
turned into alpha rhythms from the
future
it was we actually created the game in
the dynamic land medium where you could
kind of see dynamically how
how people's ideas were connected and
that was really exciting
you know they literally the paper would
light up uh and
and play different scenes from the
future in front of you um
so yeah great space yeah no i think it's
it's such a cool space and
more people should should utilize it in
the way you do it's such a collaborative
space
and let's see um i wanted to get to
another question here um and
you know you you're now been in academia
for a bit working with cal state
east bay for for quite a while and um
and arya jones or rio jones
from youtube asked a question um are
there any other recommendations for
academia to take part in afrofuturism
are there are there good
areas that this is happening uh yeah
i mean definitely like uh you see
riverside with john jennings
uh in the uh undergraduate and graduate
programs where he teaches that for
future
courses um also at ucla um
and you know it's happening um in in in
universities across land especially in
our university we have
like three other professors that are
running afro features and courses right
now i ran
one of the first ones uh uh last year
and uh that's been a joy to kind of join
in
and have work with other black faculty
and creating afrofuturist courses
uh and they do it different ways you
know so from
from the english perspective from ethnic
studies from um
you know from from communication my
field so we look at the future of media
in that case in that context
um so i think uh there's actually i know
a middle school teacher who's creating a
conjuring world's
uh textbook for middle school uh
on afrofuturism also katita johnson at
the oakland technical high school
is creating and building afrofeatures
and curriculum for the fashion academy
there
really great uh working with her and
also at the museum of children's arts
as well so it's happening in academia
and in
you know high school middle school and
other institutions
like that cool um and i want to also get
back to that um the paper you wrote for
out for futurism 2.0 where you know long
now and many of the futurists that
founded long now and the iftf
uh the institute for the future really
um you you talked about
how um how you weren't represented in
these organizations
um but we're at the same time we're
invited in in certain contexts but
um can you elaborate on that and and uh
it was i thought it was
it was really refreshing and great to
see um that context for us
yeah you know i mean i think um iftf
from when i
first landed there in 1998 as this you
know
wide-eyed graduate student to now has
made tremendous strides you know last
year they
they helped support our afro futures
festival
uh with with the black speculative arts
movement and the museum of the african
diaspora
uh too and others and um kind of seeing
their own evolution
in terms of futures thinking has been
refreshing itself too
they've done work in the sudan um
they've uh
created a good for a good for future
fellows program
where they have people from the
community that are doing really
interesting innovative things and work
in community futures too so um but i
have to say you know when i first got
there
i i felt uh i felt i couldn't see myself
in there in the future that they were
generating
and uh but they actually immersed me in
some of the skits that we did
uh you know for the future and
and and we actually did get to do one
amazing festival in
san diego in 2001 with the encanto
community
where we did have digital storytelling
done by community activists
uh for the black community there and
that was kind of the first glimpse
that i could see of that actually
happening now i wish it
had not taken as long to get there as we
are now but just seeing
that kind of embryo happening was
amazing
um you know and i notice it happens in
isolated instances and now it's
more colorless and and and thankfully
you know
iftf has trained me well to be able to
articulate this and to generate future
scenarios like
i can wake up and just do it in my in my
sleep so
nice and you um when we worked with you
several
years ago um on the um futures classes
um at uh at cal state east bay you did
um i believe you did a class that was
100 years and a thousand years
teaching effectively teachers how to
think about futures that are
that are very far in advance and can you
say a little bit about that
yes i have to have my hats off to andrea
severi
our consultant on that who helped me
develop
projects for futures thinking especially
the one that we do
is like uh you know what does your
future look like in 2054
as a one and a half page story and you
have to develop signals
and uh create a scenario storytelling
about your future organizational life
uh and then we also did a fun exercise
where it's like what are
10 things that you would want in the
next 10 000 years you know and we would
joke and say well like the beatles are
forever you know or
you gotta have you gotta you gotta have
um al green or you know sam quick
with you too um but you know so
uh those types of things work because of
course with undergraduates it's not easy
to think about you know more than a year
ahead
um but with them they what i would get
in terms of feedback from them would be
like wow you know i turned out at my
interview with
my perspective employer and and told
them about what i was doing in terms of
envisioning the future and they were
really impressed
um so we have several alumni now like
melissa marincio at twitter
and others at facebook and google
that have really been able to
leverage their insight about the future
and hopefully make it more
inclusive right that's the real goal
nice um well we're going to
close um we're coming up on past past
the hour here but
um i think peter laden uh who's watching
on youtube
um has a great question for us to close
on um and
he asks if if you could talk a bit more
about white people can be allies in the
afrofutures movement
and even more specifically how people in
a long now community
can get connected and involved and you
have some openings coming up very soon
so yeah i want to mention uh
a big shout out to one of my biggest
allies jason tester and his queer the
future initiative
um you know he's been wonderful in
actually
uh mentoring me you know as because we
came in together
at the institute for the future and he's
been just this visionary
in thinking about what do queer futures
look like 10 to 20 to you know 100 and
thousand years from now
and i he inspires me every day and i
think that's so important
um eli kazminski and others i think it's
there's a real tremendous advantage
and coalition uh being able to be built
with
um white allies coming in um and you
know
ahmed and i talk about this like what is
another term for allies
than that one because you know uh we
want to make it even
kind of a deeper intimate connection but
uh having them you know
understand where we're coming from and
listening
is really important and knowing that
black futures can help steer this
you know it's not it's not them
directing us
it's us telling them here's what we
envision
help us get there you know so that's you
know really important
cool and um as far as the long now
community i mean we have
um thousands of people mostly um
concentrate here on the west coast but
we're really worldwide and i'm
you know thinking about responsibility
hopefully over the next ten thousand
years
um and i just what what can uh what can
you say to this community are some next
steps um that we think would be
interesting for them and you
yeah i mean i think um you know
making sure that the library for the
next 10 thousand years
has uh more black futures thinking
embedded in it
you know like what you said about the
wakanda
having the library at its center and i
think making sure that
that we have those inclusive visions
embedded in the dna
of 10 000 years because i think in my
mind
it's not so much a singularity but a
multiplicity of visions
that create next stage ai
with more profound empathic african soul
you know at that at that at the at the
beginning
of our species so i would say looking at
that
uh you know having more african time as
part of our
rhythms nice well that's a perfect place
for us to and thank you so much
lonnie really great seeing you again and
having you here with your family tonight
thank you
thank you thank you so much sander and
thanks our guest ahmed and ronaldo and
thank all of you who watched
online and we look forward to seeing you
at our next event thank you very much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you